la grenouille qui n'avait pas de nez le
texte est de m'a donné et les
illustrations sont de haut à
il était une fois une grenouille
prénommée Olivia comme toute sa famille
Olivia avait la tête et le dos vers
comme l'herbe des champs la gorge et le
ventre blanc
Pompéi était un étang sa maison une
large feuille de nénuphar comme l'eau en
était recouverte elle a changé souvent
il ne se passait jamais rien au pays
d'Olivia
cependant la grenouille ne s'ennuyait
pas
par ces petites oreilles elle captait le
chant du vent et des animaux sur sa peau
luisante hélice elle goûtait au caresses
de la brise à la fraîcheur de l'eau à la
tiédeur du soleil
de sa langue rose elle capturait de
délicieux mousserons pour ses repas
dans le jaune de ses yeux se reflétait
le mimosa du printemps et toutes les
couleurs des saisons
mais de son odorat elle ne se souciait
pas les odeurs les parfums de
l'intéressait pas
or il arriva qu'un matin de juin il se
mit à pleuvoir sans discontinuer il plut
tellement que les temps gonfla gonfla
tant et si bien qu'il déborda entraînant
les grenouilles dans ces flots
Olivia Vaughan ici de longs jours et de
longues nuits cramponné à sa feuille de
nénuphar
enfin un soir le courant l'abandonna sur
un rivage lointain
elle regarda autour d'elle dans la
pénombre du crépuscule elle vit nulle
trace de sa famille ou d'un quelconque
animal
seul
ce pouvait-il qu'elle soit seule
tout à coup elle entendit le sort de
bruissement on aurait dit qu'une nuitée
de mousse voltée non loin d'elle au
moins elle pourrait dîner son estomac
grillait famine
mais la nuit tombait vite et Olivia ne
peut rien prendre pour se restaurer
elle se résolue donc à dormir et à
attendre le jour suivant afin d'explorer
le lieu où elle avait échoué
au petit matin à son réveil le
bruissement d'elle avait repris de plus
belle il provenait d'un bosquet de
fougères géantes est-ce- dirigea et que
découvrit-elle
n'ont pas d'inoffensif moucheron qu'elle
aurait pu goûter mais un énorme et sain
d'abeille
Olivia savait combien leur piqûres
pouvaient être douloureuses et même
mortelle aussi elle ne s'attarde pas
déployant ses longues pattes elle
s'éloigna dans le plus grand silence
elle s'était postée en haut d'un rocher
pour mieux observer les alentours quand
soudain la plus grosse abeille qu'elle
n'est jamais vue va lui frôler le menton
Olivia n'était cependant pas grenouille
à se laisser impressionner longtemps si
c'est insecte avait dans l'idée de
l'attaque et sans l'aide de ses pareils
elle était assez rapide pour l'attraper
et l'en faire qu'une bouchée
c'était d'ailleurs ce qui allait se
produire la fin la tiraillant de plus en
plus
tu m'appelles Sibelle je viens du jardin
en mille parfums ou à donner l'abeille
en tournoyant autour d'Olivia la
grenouille s'en trouve à forte agressée
je m'appelle Olivia et si je n'arrête
pas ton manège tu seras mon prochain
repas l'avertissait
je n'y tiens pas du tout réplique à
cybel pourquoi pas plutôt devenir des
amis
je pourrais te faire visiter mon domaine
tu y découvriras des merveilles et puis
sur le chemin tu auras de quoi apaiser
ton appétit
et bien ne perdons pas de temps répondit
Olivia
ne ferait respirer des milliers d'odeurs
exquises
tu sais moi je n'ai pas beaucoup donné
alors les odeurs
mais je suis curieuse aussi je te suis
Olivia
accompagna donc si belle sur un chemin
de cailloux et d'herbe folles à
proximité d'une colline derrière
laquelle se niçaient le royaume de son
guide la grenouille commence à ressortir
une sorte de vertige un mélange de
senteurs plus prononcé les unes que les
autres flottaient dans l'air
la grenouille n'y étant pas accoutumer
respirait péniblement et pensait à
s'évanouir à chaque bouffée
si belle lui recommanda
inspire doucement marque une pause enfin
expire calmement
Olivia s'accit dans l'herbe est suivie
les conseils de la veille
au bout d'un moment la tête ne lui
tourne plus les parfums ne se
confondaient plus si belle la conduisit
à travers le jardin ensemble elles
submer les plantes les fleurs les fruits
Olivia fut la première surprise de
constater combien la poésie bientôt elle
suit différencier l'odeur de la goyave
du jasmin de la cannelle et tant
d'autres encore
les deux amis s'entendaient à merveille
et s'amuser à mettre en pratique des
œufs qu'elle connaissait et un inventait
de nouveau
un jour
si belle proposa veux-tu jouer à Colin
Maya ah oui mais c'est une excellente
idée que tu as là je commence
cache tes yeux et dis-moi ce que tu sens
Olivia réussi à 10 sur 10 la 11e fois
elle se détendit comme un ressort recula
d'un bon fronça le nez et s'écria
quelle est cette odeur mais c'est une
horreur
si belle en attrape pas le fou rire
à votre avis quand elle fait respirer à
Olivia